in the summer prince philip was a
picture of health
unexpectedly venturing out of retirement
to hand over one of his military titles
but even for a sprightly looking 99 year
old health problems
are inevitable announcing that he's
being treated in hospital the palace
said
his royal highness the duke of edinburgh
was admitted to the king edward vii
hospital in london on tuesday evening
the duke's admission
is a precautionary measure on the advice
of his royal highnesses doctor
after feeling unwell the duke is
expected to remain in hospital for a few
days of observation
and rest at 99 you must expect
that those people around the duke at the
moment would think it's sensible
if he's unwell to take him to the ebb at
the seventh hospital
and have him thoroughly checked up it's
a
sensible precaution he's had issues with
his health before
and at that age why take any chances
and i know that the duke will really
mind because
he doesn't like a fuss being made while
the palace won't say what his symptoms
are we know it's not covered related
he was also driven there by car and not
by ambulance and walked in by himself
it is a hospital he's familiar with
after being treated there on several
occasions before
including christmas 2019 when he was in
for a pre-existing
medical condition possibly a
reoccurrence of the urinary tract
problems
that he's had in the past but since then
he has
appeared relatively well in a photograph
released for his 99th birthday
another for his 73rd wedding anniversary
and at princess beatrice's wedding with
the queen
the palace has done everything they can
to keep the duke
and the queen fit and well during the
pandemic
there's been strict covered measures in
place at windsor castle and anywhere
that the queen has
been going whether it's on engagements
or doing a mini trooping of the color
last summer in the confines of windsor
castle
and that relates to the staff and anyone
they come
into contact with such is the nature of
trying to keep them safe
from covid in a sign that the family are
considering it business as usual prince
charles and camilla
visited a vaccination hub in birmingham
today and this photo was released of the
first
sealord of the royal navy on the phone
to the queen at windsor
the palace playing down any concern
saying that prince philip is
in good spirits as he receives the best
possible care
rhiannon mills sky news